don't just stand there let's get to it
strike a pose there's nothing to it
the stars show up and show out for
britney spears big day
look at that
you like it yes britt britt is
officially married to her man askari
life is amazing and the wedding
reception was a dance party to remember
leave it to brit to always dance like no
one's watching
the blushing bride had her whole crew on
the dance floor after she tied the knot
with the 28 year old model actor with
pals like drew barrymore and selena
gomez helping the pop princess celebrate
an insider tells et selena was even
spotted dancing with the queen of pop
madonna and the bride to her hit toxic
[Music]
and check out this moment madonna
locking lips with britney on the dance
floor which is taking us back to the
early 2000s when the pair had that
infamous kiss at the 2003 mtv video
music awards that's what's on it paris
hilton was also there looking smoking
hot in an all-white black ensemble with
her husband carter and mom kathy we're
told britt and paris put on a little
performance belting out the song stars
are blind together
[Music]
before britt danced the night away she
stunned at the altar maybe i should have
to ask the fans where we should be
the couple said i do in an intimate
ceremony at their thousand oaks home i
love the most about my relationship is
the fact that it's it's so normal you
know it's not glamorous or anything for
the big day the couple went all out with
their ensembles we hear the 40 year old
singer had four outfit changes on her
big day a two-tone outfit this striking
red mini dress and a black versace mini
dress
i brought a few pictures to show to
where she was so moved of course it was
britney's wedding gown designed by
donatella versace that stole the show
she's special she's she's something
she's a good heart yeah she's again with
a good heart and her wedding accessories
were on point after stepping out of a
horse-drawn carriage covered in roses
brit walked down the aisle in classic
white versace pumps plus brit and her
husband were dripping in diamonds the
price tag on that bling
570 thousand dollars
two guests noticeably missing though
brits boys sixteen-year-old shawn and
fifteen-year-old jaden weren't able to
make it to their mom's big day but her
ex kevin federline's attorney told et
the boys are happy for britney and wish
her and sam all the best going forward
she's doing great i'm great i'm just
it's the happiest time of our lives and
we're just enjoying it
[Music]
you